CHUMLEE: So what do we have here
today?
I have a talking
Herman Munster doll.
OK.
I restore vintage talking
dolls from the '60s.
All right.
Do you mind if I
take a look at it?
No, go right ahead.
Do you know when
this came out?
1964, OK.
I know he spent several hours
every day doing the makeup,
and they actually made this flat
part of his head new every day.
But I never realized he only
have three fingers and a thumb.
Yeah.
[laughing]
I came down to the pawn
shop today to try to sell
my talking Herman Munster doll.
Originally, I bought
him online for $300.
I'm hoping to get $600 for
him, but the least I will take
is $500.
Yeah, this is pretty cool.
It looks like it's
in good condition.
"The Munsters" was a huge
hit when it came out.
I recall Herman Munster's
the head of the household.
He was part of a
family of monsters,
and they were just trying
to live their daily life
as normal people.
But you can imagine at 7
feet tall, size 26 shoe--
probably pretty hard
to live a normal life.
Can I pull the string?
TERRI: Sure.
How many things does he say?
TERRI: 11.
HERMAN MUNSTER DOLL: You
are the ghoul of my dreams.
You are the
ghoul of my dreams.
HERMAN MUNSTER DOLL: I love
your hands-- so cold and clammy.
Well, that's pretty cool.
Did you have to do anything
besides clean it up?
Did you repaint it?
I didn't repaint him at all.
But when you clean him, the
black will wash off on here,
so you have to pretty
much take him all apart.
CHUMLEE: It looks like
you did a pretty good
job at reselling him there.
Yeah, he still has the
tush tag on his back, which
tells you the year he was made.
So what would you
like to do with it?
I would like to sell him.
OK, and how much are
you looking to get?
I'm looking to
get $600 for him.
OK.
$600 for a talking doll
doesn't sound unreasonable,
but I don't know if that leaves
me any room to make a profit.
Well, this is usually the part
where I offer you 50 bucks.
That's not going to work.
[laughing]
Tell me what you want for it.
I would like $600 for him.
OK, there's going to be
no way I can get you $600.
Although it's
obviously worth $600,
I gotta have room to
make something there.
Would you take $450?
I'll take $500 for him.
I would normally pass on that.
But I think it appeals to
a lot of different markets,
so I really don't see it
sitting around for too long.
It's a deal.
- All right.
- $500.
Great.
Cool.
Thank you.
- All right.
Bring him with us.
All right.
We ended up settling
on $500, which--
it didn't really
surprise me because when
he first seen this toy,
he really liked it a lot.
So I kind of had a feeling
we were going to make a deal.